now we're going to move on to a new
problem which is document classification
and we'll use an example as an example
the imdb movie reviews database
so imdb is a corpus there's an app and
you can and look at it and it gives you
reviews of movies so you can look up
details of movies
and they've also got user reviews so
people can contribute reviews
to imdb and you can look at the reviews
now a review is a document right it's
usually a short document
and uh it's it's what people
they just say something about the movie
and sometimes they positive sometimes
they're negative
and we there's a corpus the imdb corpus
has got
50 000 reviews
and they've been rated
by
labelers
and they've been rated um in terms of
sentiment as positive or negative
right so some some people read the
reviews and decide this is a positive
review this is a negative review
and so that label has been assigned and
half the reviews in this corpus are
labeled positive half are negative it
might sound like an easy task right but
the english language like a language is
is subtle right people could be
sarcastic
and maybe using words that
you know computer might think are
positive but actually being it's a
negative sentiment
so that's the challenge here really
so we give you an example of a review
this has to be one of the worst forms of
of the 1990s this one's pretty clear
this one's pretty clear you know even to
me you know
it's quite funny this one
the rest of the time everyone else in
the theater just started talking to each
other leaving or generally crying into
their popcorn
so
um
so the one question is how do you
represent
a review which is a sort of open-ended
document
i mean the reviews can have different
number of words how do you represent it
and in terms of features right
so the goal here is to take these words
take these reviews and automatically
classify
the sentiment of the review
okay
so let's talk about featurization and
the one we're going to use is known as
the bag of words model
so documents have different lengths
and they consist of of sequences of
words so how do we create features to
characterize the document
so here's what we do
so from a dictionary we identify the 10
000 most frequently occurring words say
in the english language
now 10 000 that's a parameter which we
decide on and that's what we've used
here you could make it fifteen thousand
if you like
then what you do is you create a binary
vector
of length ten thousand and for each
document you score one in every position
that the corresponding word occurred
so every time a word occurred you put a
1 in that position
in other words the position in the in
this dictionary of 10 000 words
where that word occurred if it occurred
more than once you just leave it as 1 in
this case
so if you've got n documents now you're
going to have an n by p sparse feature
matrix
let's call it x
p is going to be 10 000 here
you're going to have 10 000 variables
for each observation most of them are
going to be zero because
you know the review might only have a
few hundred words in it
so there's gonna be most of the ten
thousand values are gonna be zero
so that's how you do it
we're going to compare the lasso
logistic regression model
to two hidden layer neural network
on the next slide no convolutions here
just a regular neural network
i should just add the bag of words are
what's known as unigrams
you can also use diagrams
which is the occurrences the currents of
pairs of words
like very good that would be a
particular
and so you can see if you've got 10 000
words the number of
bi-grams grows you know as a square of
10 000. so
they get much bigger
and in general you can have m grams
and we but we're not going to go there
today we'll just stay with the unigrams
or the bag of words model
well as a result we're showing you
two
pictures here
the one is the result of fit in lasso
and we used the glimnet program in r to
do that
and
what we show you is as a function of
the regularization parameter lambda for
the lasso we in fact we plot against
minus log of lambda
we show three curves
we've got the training accuracy
we've got the validation accuracy
we put aside a small data
subset of the data to decide
when to stop the lasso regularization
path
and then we've got the test data set
which is in orange
you can see the test and validation
pretty much on top of each other
so the validation data set and this
accuracy you want to get high
so
you can get an accuracy of close to 90
percent
correct
the validation tells us when to stop in
the in the lasso
path in glimnet
and and then the test accuracy we can
see is pretty much the same
okay so that's using lasso
here's a neural network
and again for the neural network we show
training error validation and test error
but this we put as a function of the
number of epochs
so the number of epochs you're going to
see when we we train a neural network we
use a slow method of training which is
known as gradient descent
and the number of epochs
is as you'll find out is is the number
of times you've been through the whole
training set
each time
and so you can see we the training goes
through the training set 20 times
and that can be viewed as a form of
regularization and you can see as it
goes through the training the training
error
increases much like the lasso did
but again the not the air you said you
need the accuracy sorry the outcome oh
sorry the accuracy yes
and the validation error maxes out
fairly early and then starts decreasing
because we're starting to overfit so why
is the neural net doing a little better
than lasso here you think
well it's actually not drop it's not
it's not it looks yeah it's a little
hard to see but it's not it's pretty
much
they're pretty much on top of each other
this this number here
it's maybe a little better a little bit
tiny bit yeah
and why
i it's got many more parameters right
well i was thinking i mean it's
capturing non-linearities and also
interactions right when you take linear
combinations and put them together you
can get interactions of words right
that's true which the that's true the
vassal's a linear model doesn't capture
interactions
but you know the fact that the the
linear model starts overfitting fairly
quick you know fairly quickly and so
does a neural network yeah so uh
yeah i mean i think in the in the
chapter we concluded that their
performance was was pretty much the same
it turns out that glimnet is very
effective here it's very quick much
quicker than the neural network in this
case because it can exploit the sparsity
in the x matrix
the x matrix is mostly zeros and and
the glimnet and the lasso model can
exploit that